uh hi everyone my name is dasha
and i'm the height here of this course
and it's really amazing
experience to work with you guys and i
hope you learned a lot from the course
today i'm excited to present my recent
research design space of graph neural
networks
so in this lecture we cover some key
questions for gn design
specifically we want to answer how to
find a good gene design
for a specific gn task this problem is
really important but also challenging
because domain experts want to use state
of rgn on their specific tasks
however there are tens of possible
architectures
for example in this lecture we have
covered gcn graph stage
jt gene etc the issue here is that
the best gene design in one task can
perform badly for another task
and we do have a parameter research for
each new test
is not feasible and i'm sure you have
some hands-on experience
in your final project and you know
turning the hyper parameter of genius
is not really hard uh in this lecture
our
key contribution in this work is that
the first systematic study for gene
design space and task base
and in addition we also released the
code platform graph gene
which is a powerful platform for
exploring different gene designs and
tasks
to begin we first introduced the
terminology that we use in this
lecture so a design means a concrete
model instantiation
for example a four layer graph stage is
a specific design
design dimensions characterize a design
for example
a design dimension could be the number
of layers l which could take values
among
four two four six eight
and design choice is the actual selected
value in the design dimension
for example the number of layers l
equals two
design space uh consists of a cartesian
product of all the design dimensions
really enumerates all the possible
designs within the space
a task is a specific test of interest
which could be for example
a node classification of coral data set
rough classification on enzyme dataset
and the task space consists of all the
tasks that we care about
and in this paper we'll introduce the
notion of gene design space
and actually have uh go into much detail
in the previous lecture
so here we'll just do a quick recap
so in this gn design space we consider
first
the intra-layer design and we have
introduced that a gene layer
can be understood as two parts the
transformation
function and the aggregation function
and
uh here we propose a general
instantiation enter this perspective
so concrete it contains four design
dimensions
um so we have uh whether to add batch
form
whether to add dropout the exact
selection of the
activation function and the selection of
the aggregation function
next we are going to design the
interlayer connectivity
and in the lecture we have also
introduced different ways
of organizing gn layers and in this uh
in this work we consider adding some
preprocessed layers and post process
layer
in addition to the gn layers uh which
can uh
jointly uh form a complete graph neural
network
so the intuition of adding purpose layer
is that it could pretty important
uh when expressive node feature encoders
are needed
so for example when our nodes are
extracted from
images or text we consider using some
expressive say convolutional neural
networks
or transformers to encode these known
features
and then we may also add some
post-process layer after
applying graph neural computation uh
which are important
when we are going to say a reason or
transformation over node embeddings
and some examples are say doing
graph classifications or some
applications around
a knowledge graph and the core
core of the graph neural network are
gene layers
and there we consider different
strategies to add skip connections
and we found that this really helps
improve deep gns performance
finally we'll cover different learning
configurations for ges
and actually this is often exactly uh in
current literature
but in practice we found that these
learning configurations have high impact
on audience performance so specifically
we consider
the batch size the learning rate the
optimizer for gradient update
and how many epochs do we train our
models
so in summary we have proposed a general
gene design space
that consists of intra-layer design
inter-layer design
and learning configuration and if you
come consider all the possible
combinations
this really leads to a huge space so it
contains 315
000 possible gm designs
and um to clarify our purpose
here is that we don't want to and we
cannot
cover all the possible dream designs
because for example you can
even add more design dimensions say
whether to add attention
how many attention has to use and etc so
this space is really uh
very very huge so what we're trying to
do is to propose
a mindset transition so we want to
demonstrate that studying a design space
is more effective than studying
individual gene designs such as
considering only considering graph stage
git those individual designs
so after introducing the gn design space
we will then introduce the gn task space
and we'll categorize gn tasks into
different
categories so the common practice
is to categorize string tasks into node
classification
prediction and graph level prediction
task and we have covered how do we do
this
in previous lectures although this uh
this taxonomy is reasonable
it is not precise so for example if we
consider node prediction
and we could do say uh predict node
crossing coefficient
another task could be we will predict
the no subject
area in a citation network so although
these tasks are all
node classification they are completely
completely different
in terms of their semantic meaning
however creating a precise
taxon taxonomy of gn task is very hard
because first this is really subjective
how you want to categorize different
tasks
and second is normal gene tasks can
always merge and you cannot
predict the future of the unknown gn
task
so our innovation here is to propose a
quantitative task similarity metric
and our purpose here is to understand
gene tasks
and uh in a result we can transfer the
best gene models
across different tasks
and so here's a concrete or innovation
where we propose
quantitative task similarity metric so
to do this we will first select
a notion called anchor models so here's
a concrete example
suppose we want to measure the
similarity between task a
b and c and then the anchor models are n
one two and five
the second step is that we will
characterize a task
by ranking the performance of anchor
models
so here say task a have the ranking of
say one two three four five
test b have the ranking which is
different which is a one
three two four five and test c again has
another ranking
among the anchor models in terms of
their performance
and our argue the key insight here is
that
the tasks with cement and similarity
rankings are
similar rankings are considered as
similar so for example
here we can see the similarity between
the rankings of
tax a and task b is pretty high and the
similarity between task a and c is
pretty low
and this way we can give a quantitative
measure between different
gene tests the next question is that how
do we select the anchor models
so more concretely we'll do three steps
to select the anchor models
first we'll pick a small data set that
is easy to work on
and second we'll randomly sample n
models from our design space
and we'll run them on our data set for
example we can sample 100 models
from our entire design space the third
step is that we will sort these models
based on their performance and then we
will evenly select n models
as the anchor models whose performance
range from the worst to the best
so for example we have picked a
randomness hundred models
we will source them better performance
and then they will pick the top model
as the first anchor set anchor model and
the
say the 10th percentile model as the
second anchor model
and then up to the worst model among the
100 models
and our goal here is really to come up
with a wide spectrum of models
and our intuition is that a bad model in
one task
could actually be great for another test
and we have verified this uh we are
experiment results
concretely we can collect uh 32 tasks
uh which are uh node and graph
classification task
and we have six real world node
construction tasks uh 12
synthetic node protection tags uh
including a predicting
node classification coefficient and node
page rank
and then we also have six real-world
graph transformation tasks
and eight synthetic graph classification
tests including
predicting graph average path lengths
the final topic we will cover is that
having defined the gene design space and
task space
how do we evaluate gene designs for
example we want to answer the question
like
is graph is batch norm generally useful
for gns
here the common practice is just to pick
one model for example a five-layer
64-dimensional gcn
and compare two models which were
without
batch norm uh our approach here is that
uh it's more rigorous that is uh we know
that we have defined
300 000 models and 32 tasks
and this really leads to about 10
million multitask combinations
and what we're going to do is to first
sample from the 10 million possible
model task combinations
and we'll rank the models with batch
norm equals true or false
the next question is how do we make it
scalable and convincing
and more concretely our proposed
approach called a controlled random
search
so the first step is to sample random
multi-task configurations from the
entire design space
and we perturb the batch norm equals
true or false
so for example we have different models
with different gene designs such as
radio activation
periodic activation and different number
of layers
different electrical activities and they
are applied to different gene tasks
what we're going to do is that we'll fix
the all the rest of design and test
dimensions
but only perturb its batch norm
dimensions into true or false
and in the meantime we'll control the
communication budget for the older
models
so that this comparison is really
rigorous
and then we will rank batch norm equals
true or false by their performance
here lower ranking is better so for
example we can see okay
in one application batch norm equals
true have validation accuracy of 0.75
uh but a false with only a 0.54
which means that batch number equals
true is better so it has a lower ranking
of one
and sometimes there could be a tie
because say two choices are pretty close
in terms of their performance the final
step
is to plot average or distribution of
the ranking of the batch norm equals
true or false
so for example here we see the average
ranking of the metronome is true is
lower
which means that uh in general batch
norm is equals true
often performs better so to summarize
um here we really propose an approach to
convincingly evaluate
any new design dimensions and for
example we can use the same strategy to
evaluate a new gene layer that we
proposed
so here are the key results first we
will demonstrate a
general guideline for gene designs so we
showed that certain design choices
exhibit clear advantages so we'll first
look at those
intra-layered designs the first
conclusion that
batch norm equals true are generally
better and our explanation is that
gns are hard to optimize therefore batch
normalization can really help
the gradient update and then we found
that dropout equals
zero which means no dropout is often
better because
we found that gns actually appearance
and they're fitting
more often than overfitting so batch
norm uh
sorry so uh drop out uh doesn't uh it
doesn't help too much and then we found
that uh p
red activation actually uh really stand
out
and this is our new finding in this
paper and
versus the common practice of only using
the value activation
and finally we found that some
aggregation is always better because
we have explained the lecture that some
is the most expressive
aggregator that we could have
and then we're going to look at the
interlayer designs
first we found that the optimal number
of layers is really hard to decide
you can see their rankings are pretty uh
even and
we argue that this is really highly
dependent on the tasks that we have
and also we find that a skip connection
can really enable
hierarchical node representation
therefore is much desired
and finally we'll look at the learning
configurations we found that
the optimal batch size and learning rate
is also hard to decide
and therefore is highly dependent on the
task and we found that the atom
optimizer
and training more epochs are generally
better
the second key result is the
understanding of gn task
first we found that gn designs in
different tasks very significantly
so this motivates that studying a task
space is really crucial
so if we look at design trade-off in
different tasks
like bcr proteins and small world
sometimes max aggregation is better
sometimes means better and sometimes
some is better
and similarly for the number of layers
sometimes say eight layers better
sometimes two layers better etc
so this uh argues that our gn task space
is pretty helpful
so what we're going to do is to compute
paragraph similarity between og
and tasks so um recall how we compute
gene tasks
we will measure the similarity based on
anchor model performance
and then the argument is that our task
similarity computation is really cheap
and we found that using 12 anchor models
is already a good approximation
and our key result is that the proposed
gn task space
is pretty informative so we identified
two group of
gn tasks group a relies on a feature
information
and these are some node cons or graph
classification tasks
where input graphs have high dimensional
features
and group b are tasks rely on structural
information
where nodes have fewer features but
predictions are highly dependent
on the graph structure
and then we'll do pca and do dimension
reduction
to visualize this in 2d space and indeed
we verify that
similar tasks can have similar best
architecture designs
and finally we're going to transfer our
approach to noble task
so here we conduct a case study that is
to generate the best models to unsee an
ogb a task
and to arg the observation that the ogb
molecule uh prediction test
is unique from other tasks so it's 20
times larger
highly imbalanced and requires a lot of
distribution generalization
so this is really a normal task compared
with the house we have seen
and here a concrete step to apply our
approach to a nova test
so the first step is to measure 12
anchor model performance on a new task
and then we're going to compute
similarity between the new test
and existing tasks finally we will
recommend the best design from the
existing path
with the highest similarity
so here are concrete results so we'll
pick two models
using our tasks managing metric so task
a is highly similar to ogb
and task b are not similar to ogb and
our finding
is that transferring the best model from
task a really achieves state of our
performance on ogb
however transfer the best model from
task b performs badly on rgb
so this really illustrates that the
proposed testimony metrics
is really helpful and our task base can
really guide
the best model transfer to node tasks
to summarize to summary in this paper we
proposed the first
systematic investigation of general
guidelines for gene design
and their settings of gn task as well as
transferring best gene designs across
tasks
in addition we also release graph gene
as an easy to use code platform for gns
thank you for your attention